it's easy to forget that there's a fair
amount of danger that goes with making
all that Hollywood magic happen here's a
look at a few times when it all went
wrong being a Hollywood action hero can
be difficult and dangerous work but
don't take our word for it just as the
legendary Sylvester Stallone whose
blockbuster action thriller filmography
has put him in real-life harm's way on
more than one occasion sly required
surgeries after filming two of the
Expendables movies and broke multiple
ribs during his stunt as Rambo in first
blood these were just flesh wounds
compared to Stallone scariest and most
life-threatening onset injury however
when filming the fourth installment in
his long-running rocky saga Stallone
bravely or maybe foolishly insisted on
actually sparring with his cast mate
Dolph Lundgren who played the villainous
Ivan Drago Lundgren isn't a bad guy in
real life but he obliged hitting
Stallone so hard that his heart swelled
resulting in a hospital stay the 2013
crime caper now you see me packs a ton
of astonishing visuals into its two-hour
run time with many of them relying on
the magic of CGI you think that
utilizing computer graphics would mean
the actors never really had to get in
harm's way
but that wasn't quite the case one of
the stage performances had ila Fisher's
character henley drop handcuffed into a
giant water tank so she could escape in
front of a cheering crowd her chain gets
stuck but moments from death she escapes
in the nick of time it's a traumatic
scene only in real life the drama wasn't
entirely fake just like her character in
the movie Fisher got trapped in the
water tank thanks to a stuck chain the
actor spent almost three full minutes
struggling to get out was banging and
saying you know set me free but everyone
just thought I was doing fabulous acting
I thought I was being Meryl Streep in
the tank actually I was drowning the
Back to the Future movies are known for
laugh out loud comedy and time-traveling
shenanigans but not necessarily their
death-defying stunts
maybe that's why franchise star Michael
J Fox felt safe performing his own
during a key sequence in the Wild West
set Back to the Future 3 forgoing the
use of a stand-in during a scene in
which his character Marty McFly is
hanged by Mad Dog Tennyson and his posse
while Fox would generally protect his
throat with his hands during rehearsals
they didn't seem to help during actual
filming and the actor was asphyxiated
and lost consciousness during the actual
filming of the scene
fortunately for Fox and audiences
everywhere the crew eventually jumped in
and saved him averting a real life
crisis when they realized that he wasn't
just acting right Scott
oscar-winner Ellen Burstyn has played
some heroin roles in her career but few
of them came with the level of intensity
she experienced on the set of 1973 see
Exorcist as Chris MacNeil the mother of
demon-possessed regan Burstyn went all
out and portraying the horror of her
character experience during her
daughter's progression from doe-eyed
school girl to the potty mouth pawn of
Satan but director William Friedkin
wasn't always sold on her performance so
he took measures to make sure things got
as real as possible measures that
included giving first and permanent
spinal damage during the infamous scene
when Regan slaps her mother across the
room Burstyn was tied to a cable that
yanked her to the floor after multiple
tags Friedkin told the guy pulling the
cable to just yank the hell out of it
for the next one he did slamming Burstyn
against the floor so hard that she
reportedly broke her tailbone and spent
years dealing with the injury that take
and burst ins real fry of pain made it
into the final cut the 1995 movie 7 is
an incredibly intense film experience
from start to finish but one of his most
harrowing sequences takes place when
Brad Pitt's character Mills chases John
Doe out of his apartment building the
scene has Mills fall off a fire escape
onto his arm before getting whacked in
the same arm by a crowbar it makes sense
when Mills shows up with a cast on his
arm later in the movie but what most
moviegoers don't know is that the cast
was real while filming that scene Pitt
had to leap across the rain-slicked
hoods of moving cars according to
reports he slipped on one of them and
smashed through the windshield slicing
through one of the tendons in his arm
considering how much worse the accident
could have been an arm full of stitches
probably didn't seem that bad
The Wizard of Oz dazzled moviegoers in
1939 with its Technicolor vision of Oz
but not all of the actors escaped that
movie magic unscathed Margaret Hamilton
who played the Wicked Witch of the West
came away with the worst of it after a
stunt left her with third-degree burns
well during the scene in which the
Wicked Witch interrupts the festivities
in munchkin country Hamilton makes a
dramatic exit by disappearing in a cloud
of fire and smoke the trick was she felt
through a trapdoor in the set that was
hidden by a plume of smoke and once she
was safely out of harm's way a jet of
flame completed the effect for the
camera and one take however the trapdoor
didn't open when it was supposed to and
Hamilton got caught in the pyrotechnic
flamethrower which severely burned her
hands and fates in that big black
witches robe it's a miracle she didn't
completely catch on fire as countless
filmmakers have learned the hard
making movies in or around water can be
incredibly difficult for the cast of
1989 see abyss which tells the story of
a crew that finds more than they
bargained form and they try to recover a
sunken submarine things were
particularly tough star Edie Harris
nearly drowned while filming one
sequence when he waited until the last
minute to ask for air and then had to
wait an extra couple of white-knuckle
seconds while an upside-down regulator
was refitted the actor told the New York
Times once the regulator was put in
upside down so that one half of what was
going into my lungs was water for a
brief second I thought this is it then I
was mad at myself for feeling that panic
Harris should have taken it a little
easier on himself it's hard to imagine
anyone not panicking when their seconds
away from drowning check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]